hello I finally found a brand new camera
and I'm recording Siri I want to record
a series of videos about an aspect of
language learning that really they
really like and it's about pronunciation
and intonation so the I did call this
video native accent and foreign
languages because what I want to discuss
today and the following are two videos
is acquiring a native accent from
language learning so when you pick up a
language the first question the first
three questions that you have to ask
yourself it are the following is it an
effort worth making is it achievable for
everyone so we include it you meet and
should we simply strive for a
intelligibility to being intelligent
eligible for being understood and just
speak well speak the language well so
should we strive for a just a decent
accent and not a native like accent um
there is a group of people who think
that speaking with a native like or a
native accent is not a very realistic
goal because the majority of people
struggle with accents in general and so
they just what they should do is just to
enjoy the process of language learning
and enjoy speaking a language well no
matter how they speak well with it with
that an understandable accent of course
there's another group of people maybe as
a minority who thinks that it is
possible to speak with the native like
accent or native having a native like
pronunciation I belong to this group of
people because they think that speaking
an accent speaking a language well is
the process of a lot of work that he put
into it a lot of energy and passion but
for me it is something feasible it takes
time
um so the first in there there's another
series of questions and one should ask
that oneself before continuing is that
um what are the barriers of talking and
language well there is a lot of there
are two main factors there's a lot of
factors but I just try to visualize two
main factors here and the first one is
it is a psychological factor and there's
a lot of people especially and adults
who fear appearing clumsy in front of a
native speaker who fear saying something
inappropriate or afraid of saying
something inappropriate or uh like
having a conversation with a lot of
pauses and there is also a physical
factor that is the the fact that
speaking a language is also a matter of
articulating sounds with your mouth or
talk with with your mouth your tongue
the muffy or muscles your throat glottis
there's a lot of things involved in the
process so it is both psychological but
also physical in in general native like
pronunciation as a result of picking up
language learning to pronounce words
single words very well and then move it
on to the intonation of a whole sentence
the problem is that uh learning learning
a set of sounds because every language
has a limited set of sound is feasible
yeah it's something that will take time
of course as as it always the case with
languages but given the delimited elta
of dissatisfy
analytical tools such as IPA that pack
can come in handy in this process uh and
of course there's the aid and help of a
native speaker so in this regard it is
something an aspect that can be analyzed
in language learning the problem is that
when somebody speaks a language very
well or native with a needle like
anunciacion they figured out in a way
their brain figured out in a way health
of upper sentences in the right way that
means - they picked up the musicality of
a language so in a way it's not in the
musicality of language that is the flow
of words and the way they are aggregated
and attached together is something that
cannot be analyzed as easily as as the
single words of a language and this is a
very important aspect in language
learning a lot of books don't just
consider this aspect they do take into
account that there is a musicality of a
language maybe in the introduction they
just deliver a small and brief
introduction about on this a spittle of
languages but they don't dig into it I'd
like to in this first video I'd like to
make a take an example of my mother
tongue which is Italian and let's
consider for example a simple word a
single word a verb like a let's take
which is plain diamo if you if if one
considers just this word which is been
llamo it this is a three syllable word
um right now if you know Chinese tells
it would be even easier to understand
but Italian is not a tonal language but
you can use pitch and you can use tone
Chinese stones to describe it if you say
putting down for example you have for
all those who have already dabbled in
Chinese and Oh speak it well in Italian
if you have a three syllable word and in
the accent the India tonic it's called a
gentle tone Eva which is the falling
tone falls in the second syllable
everything that precedes this this
ochenta Toni ko is up it's pronounced
like a first tone in Chinese then you
have a chant Oh Toni ko and then you
stay low so in this case you say bring
so it's spring yeah no premium okay this
is the this is a single word but the
prow
okay let's let's suppose that you have
learned how to perfectly pronounce this
word but let's suppose that you have to
to to say to talk to your friends while
driving and you know driving to
somewhere and you have to say let's take
the highway can you say bring llamo
autostrada if you take a look if you if
you listen attentively to this sentence
there's a total shift because in the
single word you say bring yeah but here
you have bring llamo law to Strada
because in Italian they attach Italian
attaches lots of words and if if you
consider the whole in this in this case
you consider a whole send a whole
sentence this is just one more in
Italian printable autostrada this is the
autostrada folsom Strada
all the things that precede the falling
tone is up so you don't say anymore
pretty amo but you say brendi amo la
tostada so there's a tonal shift this is
just a very tiny example to explain to
you that a pronouncing a pronouncing
words correctly learning how to
pronounce a single phonemes and words
correctly does not necessarily mean that
you can pronounce a sentence for a while
so in following video which is video 2 i
will try to visualize a more concrete
methodology to that I personally use I
don't think you can find it in books
here although there are a lot of books
talking about intonation but this is
more like a pragmatical way of dealing
with intonation and not pronunciation of
single sounds so thanks for listening to
me and see you in the next video